in my last video i wasn't able to talk
much about berserk as a series much
just because it was a very raw and short
kind of unscripted tribute
in these past couple of days across the
whole anime and manga community
berserk is all that's been on most of
our minds
so i wanted to make at least one more
video in honor of the series and the
parts that i love about it
and as i mentioned in my last video one
of the things i love most about berserk
is the fan base the fact that so many
different kinds of people
from new younger kids interested in
anime
to grown men who have been with the
series from the start
we're so unified in our love and passion
for the series
as we follow guts on his adventures
and so today i'm talking about the parts
of the series that i feel made it
resonate to such a diverse fan base the
storytelling aspects that reach to
anyone and tugs on their heartstrings
despite where they're from
or what they've been through because i
feel like if there's one thing berserk
can do
or has done from the last couple days
it's bringing people together
roll the intro
what i first want to talk about is the
concept of the struggler
after the eclipse guts is labeled with
this title
as he's the sole force to battle against
the immeasurable tides pushing against
him
the god hand apostles the world itself
the moment guts was marked with the
brand of sacrifice he was destined to
struggle endlessly against the darkness
and what i love about the idea of a
struggler is
in a way how utterly relatable it is how
gutz's struggles can be taken out of the
context of the story and applied to
just about anyone reading it let me
explain a bit further
as the struggler guts never really gets
a win
after finding a home in the band of the
hawk and finally reaching the success
and fame that they all collectively
strived for
it was stripped away at the eclipse
after finally finding love
in casca she is abused in front of him
and her mind is clouded after the
eclipse
after saving kaska at the tower of
conviction it comes at the cost
of griffith's rebirth of the entire
world
changing once again there is never a
time when guts wholeheartedly wins
anymore there is always another threat
or challenge rounding its head right
after he gets one
he is in every sense of the word the
perpetual
and endless struggler he can never relax
his body or
mind as spirits constantly berate him in
the night and because of his armor his
body is constantly pushed to the
absolute limits
far past just what a mere human can do
but there are moments short fleeting
moments
after a long battle when everything
feels all right
like it'll all be okay even though
there's a part of us that knows that
by the next chapter it probably won't be
okay
berserk teaches us to be satisfied with
the small things
to be happy with just the fact that
you've managed to live
another day and that is the inherent
beauty
of being the struggler all of us have
struggles in our lives and rarely will
there come a time when everything is
peachy and perfect
even at the current part in berserk on
elfheim though everything is probably
the most peaceful it's ever been in like
20 years since the golden age arc
it is far from perfect casca is still
ridden with ptsd guts still can't handle
the
uncontrollable burden and rage of the
berserker armor
life will never get to the point where
there's nothing to worry about
something that berserk makes painfully
clear through guts's endless suffering
throughout the story
and this is one of the most important
ways that mira's work
resonates with people even though it is
at just surface level
a manga about a guy killing monsters
no one has it as bad as guts does seeing
guts fail
or lose a fight is heartbreaking because
it's just about never
fair to begin with he's fighting against
monsters beyond a normal human's
comprehension
but he sucks it up and continues
fighting against odds that
never favor him and comes out on top it
makes
all of our mere struggles feel
manageable
we can connect with guts because we've
all had problems
and we have to find those key moments
the small things that make fighting on
worth it that is the meaning of being
the struggler
what i also think is just an absolutely
phenomenal part of berserk in a
storytelling aspect
is the stakes it sets this is one of the
biggest distinguishers between
generally saiyan and shonen manga is the
idea that at any point in the story
one of your favorite characters can die
or lose just like that
that the villains will probably end up
winning a lot of the time
granted it's not like shonen maga don't
have stakes though
but in most stories the stakes are
established in generally the same way
either the main character will face a
huge loss but still survive of course
showing the readers or watchers that
it's not as easy as just winning every
time
or one of the main characters friends or
loved ones will die by a villain and
establish the stakes indirectly for
example
in sports manga it almost always takes
the shape of the former
with the loss to alba josiah and haikyuu
the lost to data
and hajimeno ippo after the first couple
introduction arcs our main characters
almost always face a big loss
to kind of bring us back to the ground
and understand that not everything is
that easy
we also see it in fullmetal alchemist
with the first fight against scar that
ends in complete failure for the elric
brothers or the reveal of eisen's plan
and betrayal at the end of seoul society
and in the other case there's situations
like the death of jaraya and naruto or
kamina in gurren lagann
i'm sorry if these are spoilers i tried
choosing shows that are pretty old or
pretty well known by this point and then
there's manga that do both
like one piece with the loss at sabaori
and then the major death in marineford
and berserk does this as well it does
both but in a way that far
surpasses the loss and scale of any
other manga or anime in my opinion
through the eclipse after the long and
absolutely masterful duration of the
golden age arc it climaxes in the
eclipse
and up until this point it was already
clear that everyone was fighting with
their life on the line in berserk
it was pretty obvious but with the
failed assassination attempt on griffith
guts surviving against a hundred
soldiers
it felt like our main cast was even in
the worst possible situations
always going to pull through that is
until the eclipse happened the moment
that every single character we had grown
to love was killed in
one fell swoop and if they didn't die
like kaska her mind was wiped and her
body was violated
guts went through the mental torture of
witnessing that all plus
losing his arm and eye not only did guts
himself
face a huge loss but we saw the death of
not just one of his close friends
but all of them it makes it clear that
berserk
isn't playing around that these lives
can disappear in
any second and the eclipse raised the
stakes of this series to an
unreachable standard it's truly the
pinnacle of the jaw-dropped
eyes-wide holy crap moment that you
rarely come across
in anime or manga you feel like if
there's anything bad that can
potentially happen
it will happen in berserk and it makes
the trials guts goes through
all the more visceral he's fighting and
both the reader and him know that
one wrong move means that he dies and
everyone he's protecting dies with him
and high stakes are important because it
keeps the story moving
it makes the reader want to flip each
page and raises the tension with each
flip
if the main character wins each time it
gets repetitive and boring
in sports anime they have to make them
lose at some point because
otherwise the watchers will just always
go into a game
not wondering about the outcome but just
wondering about how they'll win this
time
it takes a huge aspect of a good fight
or good match out of the equation
and leaves the story kind of hollow and
in berserk with the eclipse it shows
that the stakes are at the highest level
possible
it is the ultimate reminder that in the
world of berserk
loss is everywhere no one is exempt
i think that the eclipse and the
establishment of stakes works really
well with the first aspect i mentioned
as well which is the presence of the
struggler
not only does it make gut's struggles
feel real like there's a real reason
that he's fighting
to avoid the fate that the band of the
hawk experienced
but it also makes those small moments i
was talking about earlier
even more satisfying even though they're
so short and fleeting
you feel so much happier with them that
against all the odds guts and his crew
managed to make it out through their
will to continue
it gives the reader strength i saw this
a lot in the comments on my last video
how berserk brought a lot of people up
in a dark time and period of their life
and i think all of this is a big reason
why
it can connect to anyone who's struggled
or had issues before through guts's
story despite how
fantastical and dark it is i think it
can be attributed to masterful writing
on mira's part and just
great use of storytelling devices in
general
i love berserk i haven't read it in a
while but i think after everything
that's happened i'll probably reread it
and once again
see the beauty of this series i hope you
guys enjoyed
the video and as always this has been
the anime culture corner don't forget to
like and subscribe for future in-depth
show
manga and character analyses
you